bonjour à tous je suis de retour pour
les commentaires du match entre cette
fois c'est entre stefanova et des six
core i donc ça va être très intéressant
de regarder ça donc ils en sont où
la deuxième partie là donc la première
partie c'est ses fans pas qu'ils aient
gagné donc voyons voir comment ça se
passera
[Musique]
ok donc il y avait un petit souci avec
moi au billet c'est le temps ne tournait
pas en fait donc voilà c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait ça et du coup là on aime on
est de retour donc désolé donc espérons
que la le temps continuera tournée donc
voilà donc c'est la deuxième partie donc
c'est mon à son candidat
donc ça c'était les coûts quatre des
cinq risques et donc en général dans la
scandinave le clan des cartes peut être
un peu faible en cadeaux petits devant
roc et de et de pousser le simple
peut-être mais aulas a l'air de cette
pente des cas où ces housses et enfin
pour les mains donc là je pense que elle
va faire elle va pas faire un groupe
parce que du coup aux racailles et b4
qui va arriver donc va plutôt faire
petit rock je pense ou alors tu as des
cavaliers h4 aussi pour interview sur le
fou est encore de quelques crans et
royaux y aura prise hier on s'en fiche
un peu dit depuis un doublé ça se tend
30 points
bon du coup elle réfléchit elle
réfléchit donc je pense qu'elle va faire
moi à sa place je ferais peut-être petit
rock ou alors qu'à bailliage 4 après je
sais pas peut-être qu'elle veut prendre
mais la prise ça me semble pas vraiment
nécessaire parce que sur fou prend il y
aura ces trois peut-être mais c'est vrai
que c'est une pollution pas de mal pour
les blanches mais c'est pas nécessaire
je pense de fait ça vaut mieux faire un
truc du genre turcs parce qu'elle l'a
apprise en c3 où joueurs et la poule b
et ça serait ça serait bon pour nous
donc ça ne me dérange pas
donc juste pour le faux locke qui
rappelle ça c'est ça c'est le match
numéro 4 y avait déjà eu trois matches
avant celui ci allait il était tout seul
et que plus intéressants les uns que les
autres
et voilà ça c'est le match numéro quatre
donc on a déjà les noms des défunts que
ce qui parce qu'on l'a à la deuxième
phase
donc là on attend de voir qui c'est
qu'il ya dans l'antre entre celle là
donc kvh casser le cou que jeu auquel je
pensais donc la prise prise je pense que
c'est très bien pour les blancs ça
devrait la colombe et ça l'a vraiment
top
ou encore voilà 5
c'est une bonne manière de décès d'abord
un peu de contre aux jeux mais ouais
mais diouf on sait c'est pas si grave
que ça parce que je pense qu'il y aura
des tours bien qu'ils attaquent le pion
bessette et que si jamais on est heureux
il y aura la reprise on reprend
simplement et sur cavaliers pros ont
fait faux comblessac donc c'est pas
rentrer aussi des sacs poubelles donc
elle n'a pas ici elle n'a pas laissé de
prix ce encore mieux je pense mais mais
du coup ça ça bloque la cool à la
diagonale du fou c'est peut-être un peu
embêtant ce bout des seins acté que
peut-être que c'était mieux de parfaire
en fait de faire plutôt tout un tour
bien tomber un ça m'a l'air en plus
normal
ou alors même si rock en fait tu veux
que ça a l'air pas mal aussi
donc ok donc la jouer des simples ça et
c4 c5 salaire normal aussi parce que le
fou protège stoppions mais du coup là
les noirs ils ont beaucoup de contres
jeu si jouer eux quatre équipes rennes à
l'option des sens qu il peut aussi faire
des trucs du genre f4 me-f perdre le
procès de f4 c'est que ça donne la case
de 4 donc il y aura pas vraiment de
façon continue et l'attaquent d'heure
donc à mon avis il vaut mieux faire re 4
donc là je cahier 17 hockey pendant que
là peut-être des tours tours mais trois
celui de tourbe et un essai de datta
khel tuant 17 poursuivre notre âme notre
idée voilà ça ça m'a l'air plutôt bien
donc j'imagine cavale peur à moins
qu'elle ait peur de ce f4 f4 on parle
plus avec le fou peut-être même en d2
mais duke ou f4 ou des deux il y aura
qu'à payer ses 5
ouais c'est qu'elle est syndicaliste et
5 c'est embêtant
du coup on est obligé de repartir et
après il y aura peut-être qu'à veille à
4 si on repart en mai deux bassets pas
ces basses et simple
du coup ça si c'est passé le tour mais
trois êtres quatre fous à fois c'est
carrément ok donc les belles images x 7
sont donc ça a l'air super bien en fait
ça a l'air vraiment top
l'ordi et fraisse d'accord mais dis
juste que quatre en fait ça et ça c'est
bien pour les noirs mais je pense que
personne ne jouerai 4 ici
il dit que c'est que c'est quand même
gros avantage pour ignore s'il ya eu 4
mais c'est vraiment le seul coup en fait
tous les coups sont perdants parce qu'il
ya la menace tourbillon qui arrive
étroits avec new wave 3 yaggeuses faut
prendre tout reprend h3 et j'imagine
qu'il y aura tout revient parce que et 4
ne sera pas de ramona mary manas parce
que le fou défendre la case argent du
coup le roi peut aller se cacher en f1
sans souci bonjour cesco locaux que
j'espère que j'ai dit ça fait
correctement bah alors ça dépend y en a
qui enfin ça dépend aussi de la maturité
de l'enfant
s'il aime bien aussi des échecs qui peut
commencer quand il veut mais faut pas
forcer en gamme en effet commencé s'il
veut pas je dirais que entre 5 et 7 ans
et bien un peu plus tard c'est pour être
pour devenir un joueur de haut niveau
c'est un peu difficile faut commencer
dans cette wii entre dans cette tranche
là pour arriver être est vraiment fort
aux à chaque si c'est ça le but bien sûr
mais mais bon qui est si réussi les
gamins qui n'a pas envie de bosser faut
pas le faux pas le forcer non plus ils
peuvent jouer comme ça et c'est bien du
coup c'est bien un projet pour les
enfants de jouer un de jouer quand ils
sont jeunes tant qu'ils font pas du
travail intensif qui leur servir à rien
parce que du coup ils ont pas vraiment
les capacités d'apprendre d'apprendre
aussi afin d'apprendre la stratégie tout
ça donc
du coup là ils ont remises en europe
mans sur une nouvelle donc là stefano
voire de 2 0 ça fait beaucoup même
c'est ça s'annonce mal pour cory en plus
il ya une grosse différence de niveau
parce qu'elle est seulement de mettre en
grand maître imminent et stefanova est
un grand maître donc ouais donc c'est
une grosse différence quand même
donc que se passe-t-il donc je dirais
que ce fou il fait pas grand chose sur
cette diagonale et là un peu bloquée par
le pion des quatre mais on gagne et
d'options pour pousser ses quatre aussi
dans certains quartiers on peut faire f
3 et 4
à midi le oui j'ai commencé à 5 ans oui
cinq ans et demi en fait pour être plus
précis chest colo quoi ok ok a donc
cette chaise à ok c'est pour ça que tu
veux j'aurais jamais ferai jamais de
niche c'est en en polonais ou puisque du
coup du coup du coup je suis chiante
l'enfant connaît pas tout on peut être
j'aime en fait c'est un titre mixte du
coup c'est juste que le titre de grand
maître féminin en sait beaucoup moins
élevé que le titre de grand maître
donc en gros liquide comme ça d'abord
celle des titres ça les titres disons
métiers féminins après ses maîtres
internationaux féminins et après m'être
fidh mixte et après gros mètres féminin
et après ça passe à mettre un maître
international et grand maître donc c'est
comme ça là à la chronologie des titres
république tchèque hockey d'ailleurs
c'est quoi donc tu es expats là bas
alors j'aime rien
je pensais juste que tu as vu que du
coup ce que c'était un jeu de mot avec
caisse c'est pour ça mais du coup on
voit ça n'a plus de sens est ce que tu
me dis ouais donc là c'est pas fait
passer passé simple rhinois pour les
blancs je pense être ou alors faire à
faire tour de vis qui fait toujours des
villes du coup là il y aura city tour
des huit qui aura la prison et 1,5 et
après ça ferme la colonne des noms vaut
mieux que le nord sa fille gestion on a
fait il avait retrouvé des cartes c'est
vraiment incroyable
c'est le meilleur que le leur dis
d'ailleurs donc ce qu'elle veut en fait
c'est de pouvoir prendre 2 500 qu'il est
prise en d5 qui peuvent embêter
parce que du coup la fin de la pièce qui
sera 5 sera tagués donc c'est pour ça
que d'avoir est ferme avec des trois
tailles des quatre super bien joué
vraiment très très bon goût donc sur la
prise en d4 il y aurait eu j'imagine fou
prend ou alors qu à ependes des cinq cas
les 1er 5 est avec nous avec une bonne
position pour les nôtres mais yuko à la
paperie elle a fait cas et c4
donc ça avec la case b6 donc savourer ça
qu'elle a fait dans ces sept pouces et
v5 aussi j'imagine dans le futur
est ok c'est cool donc tu as réussi elle
a trouvé en diable à bajaur est ce que
tu parles tchèque ou en août à trouver
entre eux qu en ligne peut-être ou à bas
ce que fait du coup j'imagine ça devrait
pas être simple deux de partir dans un
pays que surtout pour bosser là bas si
tu connais pas donc des pays de l'est
bah en fait je vis dans un pays vaste je
vis en géorgie juste en mai bon du coup
je pose pas en géorgie
je bosse en ligne donc pour moi ça va
mais youku et en ukraine je suis jamais
allé je n'ai jamais eu lieu en ukraine
du coup c'est que j'irai au parc chef
tient qu à l'occasion mais j'ai un fait
cependant dans la plupart des pays de
l'est c'est mr à new york dans même ans
aux états unis il ya beaucoup de parcs
où il ya plein de joueurs d'échecs il
qui vous en aide en ligne dans les parcs
ça c'est assez connu ça même ici en
géorgie où je suis il ya beaucoup de
gars en parc en particulier en fait qui
à côté du club d'échecs mais c'est pas
du joueur d'échecs qui vont enfin c'est
pas les membres du club c'est juste des
vieux en fait qui est qu'ils jouent aux
échecs depuis depuis 60 ans déjà qu'ils
se retrouvent là bas waouh pas donc ça
va c'est sympa b en tchèque
ok pas mal l'anglais suffisant ok ok
donc ok c'est cool alors si ta photo
s'il a réussi à trouver un truc qui
permet de parler anglais c'est toi
palois oui enfin j'ai appris du coup tu
connais tous les tous les pays est
marrante du red star est allé en georgie
du coup tu as fait le tour de tous les
pays de l'est un peu moins
mais y'a plein de bonne nourriture
rachat pourri ring car ni même les vins
sont très très bons aussi
du coup le repas semences est parti donc
là c'est un peu difficile pour les
blancs du coup ils ont appris avec la
case la lune le fou contrôle bien donc
c'est pas trop trop m
mais c'est quand même pas si top parce
que le late ou peut-être rentrer aussi
il ya des problèmes sur cette diagonale
et aussi des pièces soit un peu plus
active en la lah sur la prise d'angers 4
fou prend le fou contre un contrôleur à
la case bien donc ça veut dire que la
tour pourra rentrer en d2 à ces bateaux
ok c'est cool c'est qu'on va d'ailleurs
donc je commande au cfai a aussi souvent
de la nuit de la nourriture à
l'ukrainienne j'ai trouvé en resto que
j'aime bien me suis donc boire jeunes
hommes sont assez forts times ils
doivent entre 1800 et 2000 sens je
dirais les joueurs d'échecs
parce qu'ils jouent toute la journée du
coup forcément en fils on peut un peu
d'expérience
oh oui en france wayana ça ça c'est sûr
en france les gens pensent que des côtés
côté un peu tard et c'est difficile
toute fraude si tu t'amènes avec pour
musique et mai mais youku baïocco est
interdite dans la plupart des autres
pays ça existe
il ya vraiment cette culture de du jeu
d'échecs ouais ouais mais c'est vrai à
paris ouais c'est vrai à lui au jardin
du luxembourg
ouais c'est vraiment l'endroit pour font
les joueurs d'échecs bon allez c'est
vrai que de temps en temps tu as aussi
on peut croiser des gens qui jouent dans
les parcs mais bon c'est supérieur
cette peña pas vraiment d'endroit précis
pour pour ma part par le jardin du
luxembourg mais sans excès c'est bien
que tu veux que tu mentionnes ça j'avais
pas j'ai vu me rappelle plus la
nourriture tchèque sais c'est qu'il ya
quoi en fait comme spécialité de chèques
que tu pourrais regarder
bon du coup ce qui se passe c'est que
tout prend j'imagine y aura tout prend
et yoro des fous des quatre qui vont
mettre la pression sur la tour et du
coup on pourra faire fossé 5 aussi aux
l'appui ont cessé ce sera très malade
mais aussi sur ses centres ouais sur
cinq j'imagine faut pas si le fou comme
ça pour continuer à attaquer le pion
peut-être qu'on peut aussi faire des
tours tour des cinq tours dessin tu vois
mes retours des 5e réussisse il le faut
contre le clan c5 du coup ne vaut mieux
pas faire ça
j'imagine juste fou des deux est fou et
3 du coup pour quand on a attaqué pions
en est de même avec six secondes ça
difficile pour elle un cap c'est pas mal
aussi parce que sur la prise le pion à 5
sera fixée mais le pion à case sera
aussi un peu faible et le pian ces deux
va tomber donc c'est pas sans problème
donc j'imagine qu'elle a dû voir un truc
sur faut prendre ces deux donc l'esprit
souffrance et de qu'est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir
ps je souhaite saisissent pour défendre
l'option et après essayer de gagner le
pion le pion 5
ouais ouais ouais ouais ça veut faire ça
et du coup et ça qui fait juste le pion
tout cela ça la dérange pas par an donc
peut et va continuer de mettre la
pression sur ses pions ces cinq
peut-être qu'elle va passer son fou
comme ça quand on avait dit un peu un
peu plus tôt ou alors passer son endroit
mais son roi il va avoir du mal vu que
le fou contrôler la diagonale ça va pas
être si simple
ouais mais bon ça va ça leur dans
lesquelles vous ayez 3 e cahier des
trois peut-être fou c4 aussi est donc l
enseigne ok donc la position finale
alors dit que c'était un tout petit
avantage pour les blancs donc je pense
qu'elle aurait quand même qu continue
elle a vécu essayer de de crédit des
chances mais du coup là elle l'a pas
fait donc elle a préféré de de faire nul
hausse tient plus dommage d'ailleurs
parce que bon il fallait vraiment des
pain du fromage fané alors si ça c'est
la spécialité du pays c'est pas bon
signe
le rôti de boeuf à la crème ça ça par
contre ça a l'air on peut mieux ça naît
ça dépend par cissé si c'est bien fait
ça à l'air d'être pas mal
bon du coup j'essaye de déchiffrer ton
message mais du coup j'arrive pas et ça
prend 10 minutes pour le faire anglais
bondoukou ont peut-être ya des cahiers
français si ce qui est assez typique des
trois dames deux favoris rock ou alors
faites peut-être partie rock indépendant
de la situation
ok donc j'aime à dire 'ok ou alors même
peut-être pendant 7 6 puis poussé
s'inclinant que tu as le colloque à
wailly sortie fait qu'il valait 1 en
décembre
la monf yahsat je vais te fout des six
sata hors norme one way dams et c'est je
pense que c'est le meilleur parce que si
elle fait un autre coup si elle fait
faux et c'est ça le foot sera pas très
bien placé
donc oui vaut mieux faire ça c'est ce
qu'elle a fait est peut-être en gros que
ça sera beaucoup plus de beaucoup trop
optimiste hic donc voudrais pas qu'elle
fasse mais ouais du coup il faut des
systèmes qui rocks donc là on peut
reprendre avec le fou au rec le pion
c'est peut-être possible pour la
colombie mais je suis pas sûr que ça
soit dans l' avantage de noir de
personnes du coup est là où elle a
appris avec le fou qui est plus normal
et j'imagine qu'elle va faire faute et
ses soins voilà pierre qu'elle peut
faire faut cesser avec mes faux 7 5
le fonds sera un peu moins de choses en
ce 5 vous mettre la bouclier pour qu'ils
attaquent le pion à h 2
ok ou duke ou alors elle a bien bloqué
avec g3 donc bon ça serait assez normal
de mettre foi en jésus maintenant
pousser f4 ou alors juste pour remettre
le foudre une meilleure classe qui sera
un peu plus à bord disons qu aura plus
d'options comme ça parce que le fou mans
et en cf3 n'y fait pas grand chose et il
est un peu bancal disons vous me le
mettre à la maison mais je dirais qu'il
ya un même petit avantage pour les
normes et nancy font s'ils font du rock
et après qui poussent des cinq mètres
avec tout retour des 8 d'abord peut-être
celle là à mettre le tour éventuellement
ensuite cédé 5 mai mans si on met la
tour ans celui qui aura le plus raciste
qui va tomber d'accord
d'abord faut faire quelque chose à
prouver ce point
ok de poids le prépare bien est ce que
c'est possible de le faire mais n'en ont
pas c'est ça la question
donc bon je pense que les blancs vont
essayer de l'empêcher quand même mais ça
a l'air fort même dessin tout de suite
si a pas de souci je pense même sur tour
des ans il devrait y avoir des 5
ouais ça devrait aller
si je calcul bien fn venir et que ça va
donc mes lordi aime pas les 5
a lille un parent à cause des f4
maintenant ok donc parce que sur des
singes maintenant vu qu'elle a bougé le
fou du coup il y aura et 4 mai et fait
la prix sinon ça leur dalle et
j'aimerais bien savoir en fait ce qui se
passe sur des cinq donc il ya la prise
apparemment
ah ben c'est ce qu'elle appelle non la
police a donc pris cavaliers prends mes
profs et il n'aime pas trop
il préfère garder l'attention le centre
est pas échanger des pièces
donc elle a bien fait de défendre son
pion ainsi il faut pouvoir sortir la
tour donc dans ce cas là le là c'est un
peu plus forte que l'exécution donc
c'est pour ça qu'on attend un peu de
pousser des 5
parce que si on fait tout de suite il y
aura plein échange et ça ça sert à pas
ça servira pas eu grand chose
donc voilà c'est pour ça que c'est pour
ça que tu ne le fais pas mais maintenant
le cailly partie peut être que ça ça
peut se tenter dé 5
je pense que des cinq ça peut aller mais
non parce qu'il y aura moins des changes
l'udc le câblier partij ouais si elle
trouvait pas prendre et après la poussée
des 5 et elle réussira à garder beaucoup
caisse au centre du coup ça ça a l'air
d'être lent donc là faut que faucoucourt
idées ici alors on monte parce que el
hadj amar à moins 2 ça fait beaucoup
surtout les deux premières parties ça va
commencer ça va très mal commencé pour
elle
donc elle a bien poussé des 5 c'est bien
donc là dans ce match vous êtes parti en
fait qu'est-ce que vous soutenez ou
alors c'est quoi les pronostics tout
simplement s'il n'y a pas de faire nos
rites c'est qu'il est sait qu les
pronostics moi du coup je penserai quand
même que c'est plutôt c'était pas d'un
boîtier qui va gagner ce match seul est
beaucoup plus forte
enfin en tout cas elle a beaucoup plus
d'expérience et et khoury je pense
qu'elle n'est pas très très forte en
rapide hélyce comparez surtout à un
stéphanois ton prend b2 c'est bizarre
bah ouais c'est bizarre c'est vrai mais
je pense qu'elle va emmener son client
est roi c'est parce que ça qu'elle a
choisi sa evo6 emmené sa tour en d2 et
pouvoir doubler que plus facilement
après ces 4 j'imagine que ça pour ça
qu'elle a pris
on verra bien si si c'est si c'est
vraiment pour ça ouais ouais
elle veut mettre sa tour là il faut
aussi éventuellement faire c'est vrai
mais du coup je pense que l'ol aurait dû
mieux faire de prendre un hic c'est qu'à
manille ouais parce que les élites
roulante avec avec tours tourbe et de
djabou ben merci pour le soutien
bah du coup enfin c'est vrai qu'une des
six corps il est un peu moins connus
mais stéphane aubin il est très très
connue donc mais bon et elle n'a pas
vraiment fait grosse perf du coup elle
n'est pas championne du monde ou quoi
que ce soit mais
il a quand même été très très forte
depuis longtemps donc il faut la
connaître
c'est vrai que l on plus en esprit
combatif c'est vrai qu'en général il ya
beaucoup moins deux nuls mais mais c'est
aussi parce que d'en haut niveau un peu
en plus moins élevé le disons si on
compare ça ou partie de carlson nouveau
partie des autres bien sûr qu'il y aura
beaucoup plus de nul à ce niveau là
parce que ils ont un niveau beaucoup
plus élevé alors qu'elle est long de
1500 2550 ou peut-être même du mi 6 ans
maximum donc à beaucoup plus de deux
parties ghani à ce niveau là plutôt que
comme que haut niveau ça pour ça
ok donc elle avait déjà joué au hockey
l'année dernière c'est qu'ils avaient
gagné d'ailleurs la dernière si vous
savez ce que du coup je suis j'ai pas
trouvé j'essaie de te qualifies l'année
dernière mais ça va trop marché du coup
du coup j'ai agi les fleuves j'ai essayé
d'éviter de regarder tous deux regards
des stéroïdes alors la dame d'amour f3
ça laisse l occurrence de reprise tel
que voulez vous aller mieux mettre le
cahier de 30
juste pour défendre le pion se cacher
boss est super bizarre ce qu'elle a fait
avec eux avec des mecs trois fouilles
avaient trop france et 4 et son
adversaire n'a même pas pris en plus
elle a fait un choix donc là il faut
vraiment faire cavalier 3 et défendre ce
plan
ouais ouais je la connais oui je la
connais d'ailleurs depuis très longtemps
fume depuis les champions championnat du
monde jeune je crois qu'il avait fait
des belles performances là bas il me
semble que là qu'elle a eu des podiums
ou alors peut-être des médailles mais je
suis je suis pas vraiment sûr mais en
tout cas je sais qu'elle a bien marché
franchement du monde des jeunes quand
encore j'étais à l'époque et j'ai aussi
déjà joué contre elle parce qu'elle
était invitée en tout à fait remis ou
j'ai joué donc ouais je la connais bien
cet égout nina ok oui oui c'est logique
binaire cette partie est ce qu'ils
avaient aussi pouilly fargniers ce genre
de personne aussi houba houba il se
passe quoi là a donc ouais donc là bas
il va gagner ça sur un match nul au nom
s'est pris et s'est pris un pape est là
et également mais du coup fallait pas
qu'elle prenne n'en fallait pas qu'elle
prenne ce pion sok-yong ce 4l ses prix à
perpète
oh c'est moche c'est moche ça c'est
moche ouais suffisait juste de pas
prendre le pion elle pouvait faire tour
feront des 5
elle gagnait tout prend des cinq c'est
le reprenait y avait il y avait imaginé
d'empreintes ou alors ouais d'un pronom
24 et d'amendés de pour faire matt aut
mais d'où pourraient demain je pourrais
le damage
a été pas motivé au fus donc quels
problèmes de connexion locale
ouais donc ces derniers là et jouer
encore donc on verra bien si elle
l'ancien marchand donc
d'ailleurs c'est vrai qu'elle est en
chine donc en chine là il fait super
tard s'il a trouvé un jour on me la nuit
pour aller mais bon je crois qu'elle a
les parties en plus plutôt que les
autres moncton ça donnera les poils
niveau au niveau timing c'est un peu
différent c'est un peu difficile de tout
organiser donc là on dirait qu'ils nous
posent ya une pause telles que celles
d'ailleurs déjà de faire un poème de
faire les trois plus de alors peut-être
que cette chaleur
bon du coup
ah je vais faire ça comme ça
maintenant vous voyez temps donc la ion
juste une petite pause je ne sais pas
s'ils cotisent pas en fait c'est un peu
bizarre
c'est du coup et les oreilles sont
encore en fait partie l on part faire
deux parties du cou j'imagine c'est leur
salle lors de la pause même mon timing
ne marche pas donc je le sais pas
exactement
oui mais je suis content il oui c'est
mon job principal
bon bah du coup vu que c'est la pause je
joue aussi en faire une de pose et je
vous je recommencerai quand les parties
reprendront du coup enfin pas de vue que
je veux pas changer de 9 m2 s'est
logiquement robles le neuf
du coup je vais juste enlevé faire
conter mois clameur sa lettre en plus
bizarre mais du coup je reviendrai
bientôt vous inquiétez pas et à vous
saurez directement qu'on est parti
rencontrer
du coup à tout de suite à la
[Musique]
c'est bon on est de retour du coup du
goût désolé il y avait un petit souci en
fait j'avais à faire marcher le temps
encore une fois c'était c'était savez
deux bogeys youku 1
voilà du coup désolé pour ça si vous
avez vu des trucs des trucs bizarres
oui c'était c'était la raison pour
laquelle ça ça arrive et du coup voilà
c'est le match ça a repris mon cas cette
nuit là donc ça c'est l'ego
voilà c'est ça les couilles anti
d'enfoncement aulas au neuvième bout et
pendant stefanova à trois points à
prendre
des six qui a seulement en pointe c'est
c'est pas facile ça pas facile surtout
la vue le seul but en autant de minutes
et demie contre 4 minutes ça fait déjà
un nouveau gros avantage pour stéphane
pas donc je pense que je pense que ce
match s'annonce mal pour elle donc
voyons voir bon plat et trois donc
j'imagine que là elle veut pousser et le
pousser à 4 bientôt
j'imaginais veut pousser le 4 est sûre
sur cinq
ouais à ce moment là sur cinq ne veut
pas possible car parce qu'il y aura la
prison des quatre dimpre en est fou il
faut c5 et la dame sera cloué donc sur
cinq il faudra clairement pas faire ça
il faudra plutôt prendre je pense
ou alors prendre comme ça peut-être et
après juste laisser l'eau pure là et
surtout laisser le furieux 3 pour bien
défendre avec quatre bons coins bien sûr
elle a fait une offre qu'il a pu le 5
il n'y a pas de souci mais peut-être
cinq sapeurs par sedan t il dans lequel
elle l'a fait ah ouais et ça les rend
peu embêtant ça a l'air très embêtant
d'ailleurs à l'occasion au ghsr qui
avait levé ce point
mais même qu'avec b3 ça n'arrange pas là
il ya peut-être même la prise en d4
ouais là il a en plus la différence de
temps ça fait beaucoup
ça fait vraiment beaucoup donc là bien
sûr si dame prend des quatre grands
fossés 5 kim sung hwan davalada donc
voit clairement pas fait pas ça
peut-être qu'il va faire kvb 3 ou alors
cavaliers c4
des processus et qu'avait lieu de haut
ici tu parle peut-être peut-être des
français 6 quai les deux belles comme
c'est que sur des français s'ils
auraient dépensé 3 ans pète et sur la
prise en dix-sept ignorer dossier prend
des deux dons encore elle perdrait deux
cavaliers donc malheureusement c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
et c'est maintenant c'est un stand
parlant cul parce que sur ça sur ça il y
aura foule
c'est vrai que y'aura fouet trois en
fait attend peut-être que ça pouvait
santé la prise sur sa fougue 3 ouest et
que ça allait un peu tu baves du coup là
parfait d'affairé la fedom prend 2,4 sur
donc d'un prend peut-être cavaliers
prend fous ces 5
ok donc elle a pris comme ça ça a l'air
trés être un huissier pour les blancs en
plus ce niveau tant elle est là vraiment
des soucis là qu'elle prend des
ceintures peut-être qu'elle prend elle
prend le pian saura très faible en d5
il y aura aussi les problèmes sur cette
diagonale peut-être d'un prend des
cadres suivis de fou c'est simple qui
peut être ou alors juste faire des
cahiers 6 pour attaquer ce pion est
depuis en dessin
oui l'échauffement de les championnats
du monde d'échecs son mix oui mais il ya
aussi il ya aussi un entier spécialement
pour les féminines mais bon mot ball au
championnat mixte enfin je pense qu'on
est dans les toute l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs s'est jamais ri quand kim ne
joue donc je pense que même pour garer
là jamais faire elle l'a jamais même été
proche de faire les choix du monde mx
donc donc lol officiellement c'est mixte
même enfoncé on sait bien qui c'est qui
va et qui va vraiment y jouer c'est un
pion puces c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
bon là il a déjà été prions il n'a pas
tenu très longtemps
ouais peut-être dans je pense dans 20 ou
30 ans il y aura peut-être des chansons
mais mes mains mais bon je sais pas je
pense pas que ça arrivera à la il ya
peut-être faut prendre des deux suivis
de cavaliers 3 ouais ouais ça c'est
gagnant pour les normes encore ça ça a
l'air vraiment vraiment très dangereux
tout prend des deux tours des 8 suivi de
cavaillon 3 et après la tour qui vient
en d2 ça c'est vraiment super cette
position
du coup qu'est ce qui s'est passé oui
donc l article 7 partis fait cacher son
cavalier la wii du coup maintenant et
gagne h 2
mais f5 était un fils du coup c'est pour
ça qu'elle a défendus d'abord donc mais
dont la sève menace vraiment de prendre
la jeune et en plus ça peut faire tour
d2 pour le prendre avec la tour si elle
veut qu'avec des cadres c'est un peu
bizarre mais du coup ça parce qu'elle a
gaffé welle a gaffé
vous pouvez aussi totalement fine ça
c'était fade away prendrait un gros
avantage dans la 4k 30
on s'est vraiment c'est quasiment fini
6e
si d ici ne fait pas d un ouais je ne
joue pas mieux pendant les combats
cadence saura un peu plus plus rapide ça
sera vent très difficile pour elle si
elle a trop bas vers ce point de dix ans
donc quelque chose comme ça en tout cas
enfin on n'espère pas parce qu'elle est
quand même elle est quand même sympa
donc on n'espère pas ça pour elle j'ai
trois votes donc moi je ne joue au foot
est roi mais j'ai trois c'est aussi la
grande je crois que c'est encore de ça
encore plus connu que vous foutez trois
fous je devais way pour occuper l'un des
god and mail a pas fait encore voilà la
pin up parfait elle a fait j'ai quatre
d'amour donc la foule je pense que c'est
normal mais elle a permis de le faire
donc ce coup là donc elle veut chasser
ce fou mais peut-être y aura juste
décalé c6 qui attaquera l'option des 4
mais vu qu'elle redouble
j'ai vu qu'elle joue vite peut dire que
c'est une prépa elle connaît bien ça
loin du coup calisesi soit elle la fait
pas la fête
du coup ça serait bien qu'elle gagne
cette partie là si ça lui arrive faut
surtout qu'elles ont vite elle se
retrouve pendant longtemps donc là elle
après ça aide un peu les noirs parce que
du coup ça ouvre à la colonne h sound si
on regarde la pression sur le puits en
d4
il y aura beaucoup de soucis pour les
blancs y aura peut-être gros rock suivi
deux simples aussi pour être à quel
point en d4 et prendre des cartes tour
tu prends bessette tour des huit ça a
l'air bien ça ça a l'air bien calé
prendre des 15 parce que le roi il sera
vraiment exposé
je pense qu'elle peut tenter sa roue
alors elle peut faire une erreur que
c'est tout à fait normal aussi faudra
attaquer le fut en d4
ouais pas remarqué ça aussi ouais ouais
j'avoue apparemment du côté des blancs
elles ont du mal avec la théorie donc
elle a choisi kirop grand rêve donc là
elle attaque le puits en d4
il y aura du mal à se défendre comme ça
j'ai ça c'est bien vu parce que dans
certains cas elle peut faire un an déjà
et chassent le cavaly donc ne pourra
faire des cavs et yeux car peut-être ou
alors simplement pousser des cinq donc
sur cavaliers acheter je pense qu'elle
va pousser des 5 et sur québec at il y
aura 3 donc c'est pour ça que d'abord
elle fait g5 parce que 100 g 5 6 ici
elle faisait des cinq sur calais b 4
elle ne pourrait pas faire à 3 parce
qu'il y aura la prison des cinq breaks à
l'épreuve des 5
il voue beaucoup mieux pour elle d'avoir
fait g5
c'est une bonne idée donc là ne
réfléchissent cavalli h sont donc ça me
paraît normal mais youku y aura des 5
on l'a dit qu'ils allaient y sera obligé
d'aller en un sens oui là c'est
quasiment sûr qu'elle va faire des
simplismes ans sinon je vois pas trop ce
que ce qu'elle veut faire des cinq
cavaliers ou cinq ils imaginent et après
peut-être d'amd 4 ou moi j'allais guerre
fou au 3 mai sur fou et royaux racaille
c4 qui va vraiment attaquer d'autres
trop de choses ah non non cas veilleux
5-fu 3 qui essaient castilla dame g4
c'était deux essais à attaquer
doublement penser cette double attaque
une double attaque
cavalli est roi donc ça pour ça qu'il a
fait à 9,5 à la place sur fouet 3 je me
demande quel imprévu optech a vu juste
nous empêcher de prendre à y garder le
clouage c'est qu'elle veut faire
cavaliers n'ont qu'à veiller que ça
marchera pas si on va dans le g4 domsure
fou ou trois je vois pas vraiment de
banque ou pour les noirs parce que
encore une fois sur calais b k tu auras
à prendre
bon elle peut aussi ne rien faire elle
peut aussi faire des trucs du genre six
omlt est sûre ça a peut-être même dame
g4 quand même pour regarder le flou agca
attaquera le cavalier mais maintenant
que la donne sera découpée dans le g4
s'attaquera lecavalier un cavani
saucisses
ouais donc dans le g4 ouais c'est bien
tu meurs cavalli c'est peut-être pour
attaquer ça mais peut-être qu'en réponse
à pour alpha bank
ouais simplement avant rock salaires des
liens sans cavalier 7
bon elle réfléchit encore sont enserrés
faut vraiment qu'elle fasse quelque
chose à protons sa gestion du temps ça
va pas du tout pour elle malheureusement
parce que bon j'espère que je vous rend
peu plus vite quand même quand ça quand
ça sera du 3 + 2 parce que dès que le
temps le vu que le tonnage la cadence on
descendra t que ça la force rage à jouer
plus rapidement
tel que psychologiquement ça va
forcément aller parce que là bas et je
joue comme s'il avait tout le temps du
monde mais mais pas vraiment une glace
moment du moins d'une minute déjà
ouais c'est le jeu suit elle continue à
réfléchir donc la surca bbk qui aurait
aussi camp rock comme on a dit sur
cavaliers 7 aussi gang sur tous ces
coups on fait grand rassemblement on
s'en fiche
parce que la dame kluth ce pion donc le
pion ne pourra jamais prendre de cinq
élus restent 20 secondes au nom non mais
faut vraiment qu'elle joue pas qu'elle
vous quelque chose c'est mieux de jouer
quelque chose que nous ou la caisse
qu'elle fait là c'est ça qu'elle
calculer alors donc surprise vous prend
[Musique]
ouais mais ça ne marche pas ça wall e
deux cas dans français deux roues en f3
peut-être ou alors même roue en f1 suivi
de revient ou h1 h2 le roi se cache mes
courses et c'est bien que les temps de
ça alors du coup elle complique un peu
les choses mais mais du coup elle a
quand même beaucoup sacrifié pour pour y
arriver
sacrifiant kerry ça fait beaucoup mais
si à trouver 7 à 9 ans elle va même pas
prendre le québec se trouve à faire
autre chose laquelle le rappeur vu que d
ici à seulement 15 secondes peut dès
qu'elle va jouer en cours donc la
préférée mais ok donc il a pris donc
faux elle va prendre le fou
1 prend ol 2 qu'on m'a dit pour défendre
la torah d'un français de après roy qui
se cachent dans les fermes qui va ranger
en est c'est fini
il ya vraiment rien surtout que là le
roi des noirs sera ouvert les bras ça il
y aura des prises comme ça il y aura
aussi la commune v qui va s'ouvrir
il y aura vraiment vraiment beaucoup
d'idées
comme on a dit ouais enfin bref le wave
3 c'était possible aussi mais il y avait
un peu plus de danger ou f3 qu'on
informe donc ces formules cancellara
après après repartir when you valait
mieux qu'elle efface des coûts et un peu
plus un peu plus calme que ça
bon stéphanois réfléchit donc là elle a
plein de anon elle a joué au hockey à 4
j'allais dire c'est que justement
j'aimerais bien pour simplement pour
gagner pions
tout à ça et ça peut même se vanter peut
faire tourbe et un précèdent mater
salaires joli ça c'est le lit est donc
et encore une fois gagné 5 ans j'ai
l'impression que c'est juste un massacre
moi j'imagine qu'elle veut parer vu
comme ça au genre elle a pris elle joue
elle joue une solide qu'elle et ses 3 il
faut en effet être aussi ça peut ou là
je vous pas très solides alors ok elle
veut pas solide du tout donc km5 c'est
quoi son nom de délation ok donc la peau
mais ça donc là et peut aussi ne pas
bouger ce cavalli essayé d'emmener son
aux cavaliers en c3 parce que sur la
prise en restant avec laura la reprise
le pivot des 5 sera très faible
qu'est-ce que ça ne revient pas ce que
vont prendre un simple je pense que ça
n'a aucun sens parce que si ouvrir et
après poussier aussi ce coup ça fait
bien rapidement et ça m enfin le fait de
jouer au cices ça en fait un mort à
l'oeuf où on suit donc ça va pas trop
trop de sens mais ça que si elle touche
des cas soit si elle pousse des quatre
ça peut aller
ouais ça ça a l'air d'être bien qu'elle
ait des cinq peut-être vous voyez du
coup qu'avec des cinq maintenant tout ça
c'est pas possible bien sûr parce que le
cavaly toujours en l'air donc qu'à
valider cinq peut-être qu'à ben ali m
cinq meilleurs matches et quatre en ce
moment là ouais donc laquelle des
salaires bien roulé pour les bas
salaires super bien donc je pense que
fallait vraiment pas quel prénom fallait
vraiment pas le prendre 5 fallait vaut
beaucoup mieux faire d'être détruits du
genre kvm 5 août est pour attaquer le
pion en d4
ou alors vous aussi peut-être pour
défendre le club des cinq
parce que ce qu'elle a fait ça va pas du
tout moment ce cahier sans éclat le pion
des cartes va peut être tomber
et même s'ils n'ont pas les pièces
blanches sont un peu plus active et
cette fois c'est stephano moi qui ai mal
au temps là carrément une minute de plus
des six core i les rôles s'inversent à
marans du coup à sa tête le retour alors
pour pour core i5 elle va faire la vente
est là
oui oui tu as ta rennes darius c'est
exact c'est exact
bonjour courrendlin et bonjour mise ou
cazaux
oh mince alors serait à l'affût au
milieu a du coup c'est là c'est la
preuve que c'est papa qui façonnent j'ai
plus rien moi j'ai pour rien mais du
coup voudrait faudra peut-être que je le
coup je ne change pas même l os x now
et ouais je suis de retour en mode
sérieuse g4 les caps la grotte fellag
rome aux poudres du coup elle ça a l'air
super bien pour les bleus ancien ce
trophée paraît pas quand même augmenté
avec pierre colas du coup elle va
prendre prendre l'initiative et
continuent à y gagner
ça serait vraiment bien j'espère que je
pourrai avoir ça donc ouais donc
peut-être sur sainte kamali f4 tu le
cavalier bouge wells mais kate bush
c'est pas si simple mais le cas il sera
super mal passée en h4
donc ça a l'air d'être quand même bien
qu habillage 4 disons qu'elle est prend
1,6 prisé fou g5 pour attaquer le
cavalier non d'abord faire fou je fous
aux 4 je pense pour parce que sinon il y
aura quelques rangées du donc ça
sa fougue 4 et après il faut j'ai 5
ça a l'air top l'eau donc faut quatre
salles est vraiment bien fo prend 1,5
il faut calculer rice qui se passe
tchèque qui aura f4 suivi de manger 5 du
coup ça donne à 4 7 5
ça n'a pas trop de sens ok donc elle
laisse les noix prendre le fou le fou
c'est bizarre comme choix
c'est très bizarre surtout que sur vous
apprend il y aura dam des cinq qui
échangera les dames en c'est vrai que
leur a quand même des pions doublé mais
je pense que ça allait d'un peu de faire
ça
et là je pense que je me suis permis
parce que ça lui fait plaisir d'avoir
autant de temps plus pour une fois la
une mise une minute et demie de plus ça
fait beaucoup surtout comparé ce qu'elle
avait avancé une belle passe et un leurs
tourments des one way tu vois hickson a
vomi
mailloux coup il faudra que je fasse 10
heures à harare bizet leur parti à
apprendre tout ce qu'il faut là dessus
donc
oula attend d'entendre ce pas c'est quoi
la paperie angers 2 c'est fou ça l'a pas
repris en g2 c'est une synergie
incroyable ça d'ailleurs qu'elle ait pas
pris en g2 et elle est je pense peut il
penser juste que ce plan était tellement
dangereux ça le débat sur noël c'était
une sacrée garce à ce que ce qu'avaient
ils totalement blanche m faut vraiment
que vraiment vraiment qu'elles prennent
en jeu deux noms mais défendre aussi je
pense que de vieux camions h4 il est
mort part du coût du coup sûr ça si le
faux bouge le cavaly il est juste il est
je suis ni voix disons sur faut prendre
5 il ya d'un monde à ma je crois qu'ils
attaquent le cavaly qui attaquent le
cavalier et surtout au fc sillage et 5
du coup la lah en plus courir et
l'appareil a pas joué le meilleur où il
aurait dû faire x 4 et 6 et le cab et il
est mort du coup ils allaient changer
d'armes ouais la ccin de nouveau tendus
voilà je suis sur un timbre en
réussissent donc à ce moment là donc on
parle ici
oui mais bien sûr il y avait un virage
suite mais mes hommes et youku je pense
que ça va quand même surtout que c'est
d'aidés publiques et soutenir et manger
100 cède pas ça m'a quand même beaucoup
là c'est quand même un avantage pour les
branchements sur la f5 peut-être d'un
futur un peu ce tenté comme si la paire
de fou pour les blancs fou des deux
tours si ça roule à la gaffe font assez
moche ça a c'est un homme a oscillé
puisqu'elle a fait mince attendant c'est
peut-être moi ça c'est peut-être moi qui
ai fait ça
oui ok c'était moi qui fais ça je me
suis dit ouh là là fait fou et trois non
c'était juste un vague
ayo ou là le stream à des prêts
est ce que ces revenus là bas ça à temps
parce que je regarde je regardais aussi
certainement aux fans le stream ça prend
un fois que je vois un truc comme ça
c'est incroyable
non mais c'est faux ça non mais c'est
fou c'est à face à la la c'est comme
dans la télé dans les années 50 mais
c'est incroyable ça faisait ok bon bah
désolé de se diriger l'échangé pas ce
qui s'est passé là ok donc là c'est bon
j'espère j'espère ses revenus ça a l'air
d'être normale à nouveau un rayonnement
pour moi les zanessa les années 50 les
années 90 c'est pareil tu que vu que
j'étais pas encore nés en ce moment là
par le début des années 80 en tout cas
j'étais pagny donc voilà ouais ça existe
mais ça existait quand même froid la
télé dans les années 50 non ou alors je
dis absolument non mais je crois que ça
a existé ou peut-être les années 60
ouais avec deux chaînes
pas la télécommande pas le sont pas
l'image ou là à oui c'est à des films
mais mais mais c'était déjà crier
c'était ses films muets choix que les
films us était beaucoup plus plutôt que
ça les années cinquante huit ans que
c'était l'époque diffuse des films noirs
genre
enfin c'était le genre les films des
films du genre à aller des trucs un peu
un peu dramatique
vas-y troll ok ok ok
ouaip à l'image après c'est quoi alors
du coup il n'y a pas d'image qui a pas
le son essai c'est quoi alors 1926 après
l'émission ok ok ça c'est du coup du
coup ça va là abbas et phaneuf en
bourgogne et elle a encore gagné
youku aussi ça fait mal ça fait mal
tu es revenu avec tt famille de
wikipedia etc se nomme c'est ça
le temps il s'est écoulé c'est fini donc
là ça sera la dernière partie
apparemment après ils passeront en 3 + 2
ouais j'imagine j'imagine à l'époque
c'était vraiment facile de contrôler
l'information qu'ils avaient seulement
une chaîne de télé vous pouvez vraiment
dire ce qu'il voulait
x na waie lamothe professeur yves nous
affrontons
mon du coup il se passe quoi il part
alors cette fois son bac quand même
regarder les parties
donc ça a été un peu différent cette
fois il me semble que ça ça a été jouée
la croix la partie précédente
mais ce qu'elle avait pris au beau salut
aux peuples moi je pense qu'elle a dû
prendre il ya à huy était qu'elle avait
fait fou et 3 ouais la review et 3 et
après sur sur branquet la ffsg 5 suivi
deux des cinq mais cette fois elle a
changé c'est bizarre d'ailleurs qu'elle
a changé parce qu'elle avait une bonne
position
elle avait une bonne police en avant
donc je suis pas sûre ce soir mans son
dauphin en bon choix d'abord france
ok disent n'importe quoi mais il était
libre ok ils ont envoyé dans le band aid
est à l'esprit alors
thomas hocquet newco là ils attaquent
bien le client c'est de ça va être
difficile à défendre en cas de cas de
qualité car il y aurait sûrement c5
j'essaie de faire c'est cinq manches à
l'effigié du trot ok donc ces cinq donc
donc là ce pion ne peut pas vraiment
être défendu le seul moyen serait de le
pousser ou alors de sacrifier un pion
fait défaut au f4 sur calais prend ces
deux ça serait une grosse gaffe à cause
de tour siens donc ça a l'air d'aller sa
fa l'air de bien aller pour les noirs le
tir pour la journée pour les noirs parce
que là cavalier caïds et 3 / / fous là
mais ce cas c'est le pion b2i les idées
pas prenable
ou alors quoique tête il est prenable
parce que sur tourbe et intel filiale x
3 n'en fois troillard il ya phocéen qui
revient mais du coup ça gagnent pas là
le cavalier du coup ça c'est pas le seul
ouais ça ça a l'air pas mal aussi le cas
veillez bien placés en d3
ouais ça donne bizarre même deux de
grandir quand on est con on est con on
est gosse et qu'on voit juste là les
news afin d infos à la télé alors qu'il
n'y a pas de dessin animé enfin ça
c'était une autre époque ça on peut
moins en avance ok en 1975 c'était le
passage à la couleur
ok c'est poids à non la deuxième chaîne
a vu le jour on au quai en 64 ok donc
c'est ça c'était l'heure en 67
ok ok bon bah du coup merci pour tes
pavé tu nous apprends mon art pour tous
les jours grâce à toi
peut-être car hk 3 mai h 4k et lucas est
proche et trois séries projet gars et de
votre possible accous fois 3g une
bouteille de 3 litres
j'essaie 2 j'essaie de défendre des
trucs non ses coûts de l'eau je vous
rassure
tequila bien sûr bien sûr c'est de la
vodka en fait
du coup la banque vu que le fou est
super bien placé en d4 le cac va lui
aussi être super bien passé je dirais
cap est même avantage pour les noirs ils
sont surtout qu'elle allait bien il faut
pas trop facilement passé on voit
déshydratée a bien vieilli est allé
chercher l'ordre avec ça
ben ça on a fait c'est de famille ici
pia
vous laffont prend et il y aura des
tours qui vont entrer le pense l'idée
mon tour là il y aura des petites aussi
bientôt
liées aux os l'île aux enfants c'est
quoi ça maintenant elle est à l'air
super bizarre
peut-être même temps tf simple pour
échanger les quais en double et là à
saint cloud est donc est là et on peut
perdre à 5 on dirait rome ou à bouger
oui oui ou alors ils voulaient juste
criant pions femme en a quatre ce qui me
paraît assez normal aussi mais vous
pouvez pas trop mettre la pression de ce
parce que pour ces trois qu'est-ce qui
se passera là dessus il y aura peut-être
fou 8
ouais il y aura faux et vite
le monstre gentil ok c'est une autre
époque duo gr été faire un tour sur
youtube ou si j'ai trouvé les mêmes les
émissions à 5 donc son plan j'imagine
c'est de faire des trucs du genre torah
ans et c'est de faire des maths mais je
ne sais pas si ça marchera pas si ça
marche du coup sûr surtout un qu'est-ce
qui se passe t'es tu auras tour ces
trois pour attaquer le coup ouais ça a
l'air d'aller à tour ces trois ça a
l'air d'être seule défense ou à leur
tour des six ans ça marche aussi
ouais parce que la sueur tour à 8 le roi
et se cachant bessette you pense aussi
du coup la préférait défendre le club de
et après des trucs comme ça
ag c'est un sujet 5 donc elle veut fixer
elle veut garder la défense du culte du
cavally et 4 mais ça ne paraissait pas
vraiment nécessaire
du coup je me demande s'il n'y a pas les
fruits du genre sans et a fait tout au
palais la fait j'allais dire et après
tour f4 qui crée quand même beaucoup de
problèmes
oui ça c'est un tournant en fait mais
c'est en match donc le high donc en gros
il ya seize joueuses en tout dans ce
tournoi et on a déjà fait enfin on a
déjà regardé trois matches donc il ya eu
il ya eu beaucoup de matches qui
arrivent trop match et ça c'est le 4ème
et donc chaque jour il ya un certain
nombre de matches un certain nombre de
parties par match et n'ont jamais lâché
je comprends votre six espaces du coup
c'est pour ça que ces savants pu
perturber
du coup j'ai imaginé y aura des trucs
comme ça ou ouais ok du coup elle du
coup je disais là en fait la première
partie celle du 5 + 2 et là c'est la
dérive anti en fait et ça a passé en
trois plus trois cultures du coup là je
pense après cette partie el ils vont
faire une petite pause ils vont passer
en 3 + 2 et du coup c'est entouré en
fait parce que les personnes qui gagnent
les matchs se qualifie pour la prochaine
pour la prochaine ronde et les gagnantes
les gagnantes joueront ensemble
ok ok j'écouterai ça marche c'est là
sauf que je connais déjà en plus parce
que l'île aux enfants ça me dit quelque
chose ou la licence incroyable c'est un
coin mais la d ici elle devra gagner
faut pas qu'elles lâchent la pression
ouais ça c'est beau gars à votre
avantage juste qu'elle joue vite et là
c'est stéphane maquis à tomber je pense
ouais super ou badiou quoi cette belle
remontée c'est bien c'est bien du coup
là j'imagine y aura la pause je pense
qu'il y aura la pause et maintenant ça
sera du 3 piles de donc je pense qu'ils
vont y voir un petit os maintenant je
leur cinq minutes et après ouais donc en
fait le bracket
je pense que je pourrais le bel en fait
j'ai mes scènes de liesse mais le
problème c'est que si je vous montre le
bracket idiot coup quand je reviendrai
ya des grandes chances que le coup le
temps ne s'écoule plus c'est ça le
problème que j'ai eu en fait quand je
change et les scènes tu fous du coup
quand je revenais ça faisait main du
coup malheureusement je ne peux pas trop
montrer ça j'aimerais bien mais je ne
peux pas
ce
mais du coup si vous voulez le lien du
bas jouer c'est de le trouver en fait le
c'est de trouver un trouver le bracket
tu fais le voulait
ah bah voilà il ya toutes les infos l'a
absolument toutes les infos donc je met
ça dans un chat
voilà tout les enfants-soldats donc vous
pouvez vous pouvez regarder ça à moi je
fais pas du goût du coup ça fait 7
partie 2 dans deux mondes dans mon être
je ne peux pas le je veux pas le faire
sinon je ne peux pas survivre sans dire
du coup
bon bah du coup c'est la pause
avais tu vois c'est exactement ce que je
disais tu ça prouve
voilà je fous je peux littéralement pas
survivre sans dire ça ouais ouais ouais
c'est ça ouais c'est pas sympa de votre
part d'avoir dit ça c'est vraiment pas
cool je vais essayer d'enlever salut ma
mémoire parce que si on fait sinon je
les pensais je pense à chaque fois
en anglais aussi j'ai d'autres tic genre
je dis toujours où elle par exemple
ouais je dis toujours où elle ça veut
dire en français ça veut dire
donc en gros donc je dis tout le temps
ça met du coup c'est un peu différent a
du coup dur ou du cou du coup du pouce
du coup oui bon je ne peux pas
m'empêcher un jeu joue pas ici je le
fais je pourrais pas ça marchera pas
[Rires]
je vais essayer de remplacer sa part
donc je veux dire donc à chaque fois
plutôt que que l'autre co l'autre on s
j'aime le tuer mais séparément les fatem
ok ça veut dire l'éthique saison
bon bah du coup ça apprendra bientôt
j'espère en attendant vous pouvez
regarder le lien que je vous ai envoyé
new coupe aussi vous si vous voulez
avoir des infos sur le tournoi a cédé ok
c'est des punaises hockey les fat m sur
des insectes de la famille dit amy père
me dit donc que de coder grand mou ah
bah moi je dis aussi voilà
mais ouais je dis ça souvent aussi mais
pas autant as-tu des kanaks tu déconne
vraiment pas d'heure
ok trop de connaissances 27
donc ça ça existe vraiment alors
les dhimmis faire ça je connaissais les
phalènes du boulot non c'est en gros
c'est juste des pinasses à la craie
comment y toi je suis fait qu'un raid
des chagos lui qui fit dire exactement
ouais ouais non mais c'est fou ça
il manque plus que ex now qui va nous
faire en pavés ce rêve sur bfm sur les
falaises les émules et mais on s'appelle
bien les lignes ennemies père alors non
je ne vais pas parler au top 2 ans j'ai
juste faire le top de ce bilan peut être
qu'il sera en août
non j'ai pas d'origine géorgienne mais
du coup enfin j'imagine famille georges
également parce que mon fiancé et jure
junte c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que je
vis ce fouillis fans ouais je pense
qu'elle a de grandes chances de gagner
celle fait banal et aussi a vu qu'elle
est en chine tels que en petit décalage
horaire non ça sera peut-être en plus
difficile pour elle parce que si je me
rappelle bien boye a enfin cité wailly
je crois wes je crois que c'était wailly
fin il y avait en chinois qui a fait
rang des tournois récemment oui il vu
qu'ils jouaient en fait on avait eu la
nuit chez lui c'était genre 4 heures du
matin il ya vraiment très très mal joué
du coup un oui du coup c'est un peu ça
c'est enfin ça serait un peu dommage que
ça se passe comme ça pour elle mais je
crois qu'ils vont faire les parties en
peut plus plutôt donc ça devrait aller
merci parce que merci du coup moi vous
aussi vous avez vous mettez bien
l'ambiance avec vous avec vos amis terre
au sahara prix mince alors j'ai même pas
j'ai même pas changé de nom mais c'est
fou ça recommence j'ai même pas changé
de seine et sa carène de vie je crois
que j'ai compris qu'ils étaient les
problèmes en fait ok du coup un bon
désolé je vais devoir essayer de
rétablir sa fait je serai de retour très
vite du coup beaucoup j'essaie de je
regarde se désole
[Musique]
ok super sérieux bon j'ai compris la
technique s'applique
ok donc là il en soit j'espère c'est la
première partie donc j'ai pas louper
heureux je voudrais donc ça va non si
c'est ça moi la femme est partie j'ai
pas louper donc c'était ça l'ouverture
c'était une espèce de smith loeb
enfin danse l'avez vous vu que le coup
le pire que le fou est sortie si l'insee
c'est purement une star et boyaux voir
ce qui se passera exactement way exact
ah ouais il ajouté chaque fois il
émettre un personnage en fait s est
aussi un streamer il fait aussi du
stream de temps en temps mais il le fait
en anglais le sens littéraire de
l'ouverture cela au nom du coup non je
ne connais pas la france tu peux tu peux
me va prendre des choses c'est dieu
duo fouet à main du coup mince ok
progressivement j'ai arriverait
j'arriverai à bannir ce mot de mon
vocabulaire
j'y crois à sepa sepa par rapport à la
question allez ce club pas dans une
blague ou c'est vrai parce que
d'ailleurs il n'y avait jamais j'avais
un pour y avoir une médaille
il a fait ça c'est live donc en anglais
ça veut dire vraiment esclaves il
appelle à l'ouverture ce live
donc du coup ça va être français c'est à
dire d'ailleurs
c'était hier d'ailleurs du coup c'était
cassé c'était assez mince j'ai obéi aux
français ça c'est donc du coup du coup
je vais pas essayer de chercher tout ça
prend trois heures du coup et quand je
pense à un moment mais j'ai du mal à
traduire
mais oui mais c'est vrai ou c ou c'est
juste une blague en fait ce que j'ai
l'impression c'est non mais je ne dis
rien bon je vais retourner à la partie
là j'ai essayé de tout mon possible pour
ne pas dire du coup je vais on va
retirer la partie et je pense qu'il ya
des idées comme ça en fait ça c'est ce
que j'essaie réfère tours en essais de
prendre à 6009
non mais t'as semi sable c'est juste
parce que la slap ça avec ses 6 et du
coup la semi slave c'est à moitié la
serbe s est pas notamment à sa place et
à maman chez moi du coup je sais que ça
va
beaucoup ne
non merci à toi non mais ça c'est une
temps sur ça
mais bon le cabanis manoeuvre y vas y si
d'aliant des 4 et après le site
peut-être fougueux v4 aussi ça peut
arriver ça je pense que c'est déjà gros
avantage pour les blancs
du coup tu les noms j'en fais plus non
j'en fais plus non j'y arriverai pas
ailleurs à chaque fois j'aurai ta voix
dans ma tête a donc donc je vais essayer
de rentrer dans placer sa part donc donc
tu peux par iata fille alors tu veux tu
le dis par l'aïe alors j'imagine
[Rires]
bon alors là c'est là c'est carrément
gagné donc d ici commence à bien
sauront-elles a gagné deux dernières
parties s en fout hockey oh là là je
vais être malin si si si je si je prends
je tâche à quoi ça va mal finir je pense
que dans 30 minutes je serai déjà morte
bon stéphane aubin se pend encore on
dirait qu'elle a au faux c'est faux et
c'est un bon mois de ça c'est un très
beau match ce fut aide très très joli
aj massoma j'imagine
bon si vous voulez en fait un iron man à
l'aïoli dos neige ça va why you can't
back door doraat hollywood chewing gum
van tourneau retrouver speaking ashton
et ce fut mon médecin me wanna die
d'ossau à will make a wave ou de chat
salade de la stein argus make a wave et
voilà ça c'était mon accent c'était mon
accent anglais au oui çà ou là en russie
je connais juste quelques mots je
connais juste un bonjour si toi
je dis ce que tu connais rue le russe en
fait un check caisse chase co l'occoq ou
alors la sueur fou au fond d'eux il y
aura un faux prend f3 non qu'il faut
faire fou 3 du maillot oui oui je sache
comment y aller comme pédiatrie que je
connais
davaï ouais normal ça j'entends ça tout
le temps ici l'école georges en géorgie
il utilise souvent des mots russes pour
surtout d'avaya ça se dit souvent d'eux
mêmes en mai manger aux gens
paquin diète ça veut dire ça veut dire
j'ai même passé le droit de le dire ici
sa venue mais ça veut dire mais
heureusement c'est pour ça que je
voulais dire c'est bien à genappe à dire
où p ok ça veut dire ok j'ai rien dit
rien les reins dit
ah ouais ouais ça aussi je connais mais
je connais les deux en fait je connais
juste les 28 ans rue c'est tout adapté
que
les insultait tchèque hockey
ah ok je crois que j'ai compris je crois
que j'ai compris
ouais c'est tbilissi la capitale ouais
ouais ben c'est bien aussi mais c'est
super cool calder
du coup baissier donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
se fassent donc enfin poussée des seins
je pense pas que c'est vraiment
nécessaire parce qu'il aura cavalier est
simple peut-être que la dame repartira
après on peut pousser f4 en fait ça a
l'air pas mal des cinq d'un jeu de sf4
ça peut se tenter
ouais mais sur dame du datura g5y
empêcher fr donc je pense qu'elle a fait
le bon choix
l'alaska tu aimes bien il fait pas un
peu froid là bas mais c'est mais sinon
ça c'est cool parce que c'est comment
est ce que tu as déjà rivaux voix
alors tu vas en gros tu fais passer de
900 à grand maître en trois minutes
c'est ça ouais exactement mais exact
exact ça me stresse amours là mais je
crois que je crois que j'y arrive
progressivement je vais le bannière de
mon vocabulaire secondes
de 2 900 mille quatre cent trente
minutes ok ok ça va être un beau
challenge
ça je crois
mais moi je te conseille de commencer à
jules haag robe est directement tu
arrives pas je pense même en même temps
arrivera à 2001 jeu rien que de jouer g4
ou pour les coupes
à du format a1 ok ok donc tu veux pas ok
donc tu fais tu veux pas passer en train
mise au quai pinon commence à refaire la
tactique a bossé deux ouvertures à
affaires des partis mais des amis aisée
après que tu as fini de jouer pas juste
les jouets après oublier que pour les
analyser tu peux aussi commencé à lire
des livres des livres sur la sur les
finales c'est bien sûr la stratégie mais
ça ça va bien on peut après d'abord faut
commencer à faire à faire les affaires
les ouvertures et la tactique c'est bien
ouais ben ouais il il faut penser si tu
veux si tu veux y arriver c'est
nécessaire mais c'est avec un petit bébé
de quatre mois du bon buffle il faut
plutôt aux voix il vaut mieux s'occuper
de lui plutôt que fut que de passer son
temps devant l'ordi savait pas moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien les livres
personnellement bon je mange bien et
d'ailleurs je préfère les livres en vrai
que les pdf pas de même en c'est vrai
que c'est un peu aussi un peu des pieds
parce qu'il faut toujours les acheter à
chaque fois alors que les [ __ ] petit
peu je sais pas s il y à les télécharger
ni du coût du coup c'est un peu oui
donc c'est un peu plus encombrant mais
j'aime bien j'ai bien eu enfin lire sur
les livres c'est cool
à lire lire comme ça et tourner des
pages donc là cet art 3 pour stéphane
aubin ça commence à faire beaucoup
ouais
en plus je les dis de deux de suite
c'est un put d'ici de louper
ouais c'est vrai qu'à quatre mois il a
pas vraiment besoin de commencer enfin
plus jeunes mais pourquoi il pourrait y
pourrait devenir comme ce petit à petit
ru cela qu'il a qui jouait je crois il y
avait trois ans quatre ans celui qui a
joué contre kharkov vous connaissez
j'imagine mans le petit russe s'était
enfin il appelait le prodige et ouais
enfin surtout à l'époque en idf est pur
sang âgés étaient amants super fort
attends ce rsa
mais pourquoi ben bat pour bamba c'est
ça peut peut-être que je connais pas non
seulement mais j'ai bien à ok la guerre
ok ok ok six mois qu'il a envoyée au
vietnam il est revenu très fort
j'imagine
encore mieux ça encore mieux
enfin c'est la bombe
cher que la guerre qui rend beau pas mal
pas mal
vous êtes vous êtes vraiment à fond là
bah du coup j'ai donc j'ai presque
oublier que quand on était en train de
jouer une partie là donc ça a l'air bien
pour les noirs savent se fout mettre un
peu en vue voilà peut-être le même v6 au
msb situera juste vous prendre parce que
sur calais prend il y aura trois points
2,17
ouais mais j'ai 4 mais ça a l'air
vraiment difficile pour les violences
en fait je filmais talon bobine
tu parles en commun sur en pourcent de
batterie j'espère que ça va pas
s'éteindre parce que je regardais
commentaires sur mon peuple du coup je
pourrais tu mens on oublie mais son jeu
titre est allé chercher mon chargeur m
donc je reviens la rue je reviens je
cherchais mon chargeur avec 27,8
ça y est je suis de retour
donc j'ai trempé darfour il ya des
commentaires sur mon chargeur il est là
ok bon j'aurais bien aimé avoir le truc
un peu plus proche mais du coup je vais
pas pouvoir vraiment regarder ça très
facilement à temps mais ça c'est
vraiment à c'était vraiment noir ça
c'était pas ça c'était pas moi
ok donc il se passe quoi il sert
c'est carrément finisar déjà cavaillé 6
ouais ou alors ça ouais ça simple fort
était déjà attaqué à c'est fini ça parce
que sur or apprend d'un médecin qui
avait un cavalier un nom il ya non ouais
ok c'est mieux qu'à la fin mais du coup
sûr ça ouais ok une charge est donc la
88 300 s'annonce bien pour stéphane
aubin je pense que c'est quasiment fini
se moque
ah ok donc ça c'est mon truc en fait
bizarre à rich arrivent b3 même salaire
de marché comme la vue ça a l'air bon ça
a transposé dans un type de système
ouvertes sauf qu il ya le b3 en plus
mais ça ça a l'air d'être une belle
cohésion pour les blocs je dirai pas si
mal
elle a ni bouton il reste 20 minutes
avant que ça sera l'heure des bulles est
donc les bullet et j'ai vraiment hâte
savez ça va être ça est vraiment
intéressant d'avoir pendant comment est
le piège rouen bullet ouais ça à m
dice hickory peu d'accès bah je vais
super bien en bullet qui s'est retrouvée
a réussi à faire une sacrée remontée
comment gagner dit kevin rudd d'un coup
ah oui oui ok ouais ouais non ça c'est
sûr attends mais c'est vrai je pourrais
je pourrais mettre ça en fait mais je
continue à mettre des hs je change de
catégorie 5 c'est pas mal ça c'est ça
c'est une bonne technique
voix
ok alors il se passe quoi là donc mona
elle fait j'ai trois parce qu elle veut
empêcher cavaliers f4 et j'imagine
qu'elle veut pousser ces quatre aussi
donc c'est donc bien ça m'empêche c4est
sa part toi pour les moments parce que
c'est le cas mais il peut pas trop
bouger seul le cavalier vous jure à des
cavaliers c3 donc avec bekaert voix
c'est possible aussi mon tu as peut-être
même d'un de ses trois pour échanger les
dames après le tout cas il s'avère à
trouver un ancêtre pense que ça aurait
été pas mal est la même dans cette
variante là il ya les coûts ont doublé
donc c'est même pas même ça c'est pas
top pour les mains
ah ouais s'appelle 2
en ski non seulement deux chaises comme
c'est beau ça
ok donc il faudrait quand même que je
que je que je me concentre sur les
parties ce sera ok bon du coup jusque 2
2me commenté en veut plus et fait deux
pas de paris d'insectes alors ok donc
donc la bomba je pense que les blancs
aimerait bien par un truc du genre ça
mais le problème c'est que le pion ces 3
et super bowl du coup cette tour est un
peu forcé de défendre haut mais vu que
la jouer ça maintenant c'est possible
peut-être deux ou trois roues pleines
même faire ses 4 donc ça me fout c'est
ici c'était pas très loin ouais il
valait mieux faire fou dessin et direct
donc c'est un style là j'ai l'impression
que c'est facile et blanc qui reprennent
l'avantagé un peu vu que là peut-être
quelques elle peut réussir à pousser ses
pions
ah non mais t'inquiète je me suis bien
marré 1
bon du coup on va pas on va pas lire bon
bah du coup on va continuer a commenté
alors du coup du coup pas du coup du
coup j'ai dit leurs 3 fatty âge avait
arrêté dix français en plus je pense que
j'arriverai j'avais vraiment passé de
cet avis ne faut vraiment que vraiment
vraiment que que je couds jeu que j'y
pense je vais faire des mois il faudra
vraiment que je commence à vraiment
grand chose à chaque fois ça ça me
passera la vie à bord du coup bon donc
g5
ça a l'air vraiment très difficile à
jouer pour les noirs donc il y aura la
prise poussé hse peut-être peut-être fou
prend des deux tours un des deux taux
prendre dans prend mais la dame
contrôler la colonne des il y aura
peut-être dame des sables par contre
mais je pense que les changements
d'hommes se répète pour ma faveur des
blancs parce que si on prend faut
prendre ou f3 sa menace ou b 7 et mais
peut-être que les noirs ont fait
repousser 8 pour empêcher donc disons ce
que je calcule et c'était sa salle a
prises ou f3 fou si vite ça tenait donc
à n'a pas fait ça n'a pas fait ça donc
ouais il devrait y avoir des dames des
quatre ici qu'ils vont faire très mal
sur la prise
on reprend et après on fait des bonnes
choses sur g7 donc là le sol le
seulement il l'engagé serait ellefsen
s'était tu auras même fou et trois sur
l'absence savamment top 100
à balad depuis hier fois que j'ai
regardé à ya un sacré changement donc là
c'est quasiment gagné un but klocker
tellement tellement loin ouais donc là
je pense que c'est à lui de faire damas
huit en fait et sur wat g5 qui aurait eu
des 18 pour pousser le clan sur les
chèques sont restés en bas mais la gamme
i can't buy in donc c'était sympa guy
hoquet ouais parce que sur dame c'est
lui qui avait foulé cette donc 9 3 ça
fait mal ça fait mal donc espérons pour
pour des six coloris qu'elle réussira à
mieux jouer en bullet parce que ça
s'annonce très mal pour m
là je pense que c'est quasiment fini en
fait même même en bullet vous faudra
qu'elles gagnent toutes ces parties ou
de suite mais baissé c'est toujours
possible
c'est toujours possible c'est une housse
faiblesse ouais ouais au début surtout
au début mais là j'ai l'impression que
ça va encore blessée elle a un peu
corriger ça mais au début c'était
terrible est là et c'est ça en fait du
coup a vu que vu que au début dans les
premières parties
et là elle a passé tellement de temps
hélas perdu les parties je pense que
psychologique mois la belle n'avait pas
davantage cédé sens inverse à qui avait
l'avantagé
donc ça ça rendait un peu plus difficile
le reste de son tournoi même si après le
enfin la gestion du temps est la russie
avait corrigé après mais elle avait déjà
pris le désavantage
bon là ça va hélas ce moment
12h seconde demande donc c'est pas
dramatique mais avant là une minute et
demie de main ou même deux minutes une
fois c'était vraiment trop
oh
wei c3 c'est normal pour pousser eux
quatre peut-être on peut aussi faire des
dames b 6 3 pour en contrôler cette
diagonale est aussi attaqué le pion
bessette et aussi bien sûr poussière
quatre vit que sur d'un b3 ici si petit
rock e4 sera cloué ses pions ne pourra
pas reprendre
donc là je pense qu'elle devrait
vraiment faire d'un métro
n'est ce pas que le frein
je vois pas trop de trous sur d'un métro
en plus sûr serait quasiment 8 défendre
ce pion baisse est donc elle pourra
faire un truc du genre damned 1,17 ça
prenne un mais trois mais à ce moment là
il y aura tour diront aussi qu'ils
continueraient à mettre la pression et
le cas soit vraiment une grosse menace
donc ouais mais bon sinon c'était madame
mai 3,6 effet le cas tout de suite
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait est donc
prise cavalli front haut qu'elle peut
faire du rock direct sur quelques
épreuves du rock
je pense qu'il peut s'en sortir
je vois pas trop pour aller réfléchir
mais chez basse qu'elle est ce qu'elle
veut faire à part ça si à trop belle de
prendre 5 mai prendre le sens que ça
peut aller retour surtout que ça ait
changé na waie donc elle a appris ok
c'est normal mais rfi est vraiment trop
à il avait aucune raison de réfléchir
sur ce bout tel cas la bête lors de
petits rock et que sur d'un but mais 3 a
vendu pour nous peut y avait des tours
et sète
ouais non petit rock ce pion je pense
qu'il n'est même pas prenable parce que
il est même à prendre le fou là le fou
le faux tombe donc les nord que même
faire ou à suite mais du coup faut faire
fou fou c5 ou tour autour d'un c'est ça
qu'il avait prévu dame 7,7 salaire
normal fou c'est simple pour rentrer en
dc c'est bien sûr la taille de la tour
bref hausser les salaires bien suivi de
café idée si ce salaire pas malsain
ouais moi je ferais bien que les
investissements
le fonds est obligé de rentrer en de
repartir g6 et le pion mais ce n est pas
vraiment mangeable cours à quoi
peut-être qui élève l'enfant tels que
sur sauget sicile et quand même mon job
avec dan franck ont bien hâte parce que
bien sûr le cas payet qui prennent le
cavalier en francs la dame aime ça c'est
intéressant aussi
ouais c'est vraiment pas mal donc là le
truc ariane des séquelles et 17 qui
attaquent le faut qu'est ce qui peut
faire sourire et 17 ans peut-être qu'on
peut pousser les pions mais sur sa y
aura fouet 5 à la il ya peut-être l5
donc sur la prise là il y aura f
angers 6 voyait le jour à pierre-yves
cinq là ok donc qu'elle a décidé
d'échanger d'armes hockey
nash bien vu bien les vosges au genou
j'y arriverai jamais à m'en débarrasser
à bâle à yuya fou prend ses six balles
et a pas fait l a pas fait mais avait
juste vous prend séisme aimant la la
comme elle le fait aussi sa marche sur
un fouet fx qui attaquent le cavaly elle
peut faire tout reprendre
c'est donc ça a l'air d'aller très bien
pour elle elle l'a pas fait donc la
salle s est un peu de chance au nord
parce qu'ils peuvent rentrer en d2 ouais
il ya des petites chansons surtout avec
elle va réussir à prendre n'est plus aux
attentes non non non qui j'ai eu peur
j'ai eu peur que la tour soit en prison
et on disposait lundi cavaliers trois là
peut-être ouest afin d'avoir été
organisée avec une seconde à la fin j'ai
vraiment mal pour elle la pauvre 10,3
c'est vraiment trop
donc là c'est pas fini encore mais là
tout ne peut pas prendre b2 parce qu'il
y aura tout reprend f1 qui sera match
donc oui même ça ça gagne assure on
prend enfin là et là ils allaient
décider de ne pas faire des trucs trop
joli filet juste gagner une façon simple
et y reste en fumant du moose donc après
ça ce sera l'heure du bus l'est déjà
ouais cette fois elle réfléchit vraiment
trop mais bon c'est vrai que son niveau
est beaucoup à beaucoup moins élevé que
c'était panova
bien sûr surtout le titre aussi ça
change beaucoup un grand m contre wgm
c'est quand même une grosse différence
je pensais qu'elle avait eu en titre de
m&i des gens mais je les ai cherchés sur
la fidl la pampa rue corinne donc
donc il ya une sacrée différence quand
même
c'est non mais ça c'est juste les lots
chased comme c'est pas les brésil au
sein en sont l ofid c'est clairement pas
sa pareille pour stephano va bien sûr et
là elle n'a pas sevré l'eau ça c'est
juste les los ché ce banc
seule l eau en ligne oui mais en même
temps en pierre ou il ya quasiment
personne ya vraiment là il ya quasiment
personne donc j'imagine qu'il a ils ont
vu d'ailleurs mes frangins en plus qui
avait qui étaient dès qu'ils étaient
déjà des prodiges à l'époque
donc ouais j'imagine c'était assez
facile de denfert des légendes mais son
trait il a vraiment bien joué au plus
fin il a bien marché
il ya eu des bons résultats mais c'est
vrai que c'est bien sûr cet afficheur ça
c'est sûr
starifié trop tôt eyes avec l âge à
l'époque d'ailleurs il avec elle à l'eau
surtout moi j'ai connaissez un juste à
cause du regard du monde parce que je me
rappelle au vietnam ou pas rejeté en
il y était aussi je crois qu'ils avaient
fait des podiums c'est comme ça je me
réjouis juste mais mort de deux au
vietnam poule a du mondial combien de
femmes gm alors ça j'en sais rien il
doit y avoir une centaine peut-être 150
têtes nous même beaucoup plus les airs
tête 200 250 ch et parfois vous regardez
sur la fidh a été telle a aussi fait
appel
du coup tu que tu connais bien
attendu à non mais c'était nul ça à
temps mais comment tu est même arrivé à
16 heures
cabaye est sympa car il peut être enfin
la dame se retrouve à avoir des soucis
voilà peut-être le mieux ça serait juste
de fer turcs et de sacs et le cumin b2
parce que ça arrive ça n'aurait eu faim
ça nous ouvrir à la colombie ce qui sera
cool aussi notre ou pour rire des singes
donc lapiro que je pense que ce serait
une bonne idée
s il est là cory des six corps y prendre
envie de ça sera une grosse heure bleue
pente à cause d'un f3 mais après tour b
en salaire salaire vraiment difficile
certes mais je me rappelle il ya
toujours en paquet d'histoires ça c'est
sûr
c'est là aussi que qu'on a découvert des
des fruits genre fruit du dragon
d'andenne des trucs alors vraiment
exotiques
cette école le vietnam quand même j'ai
bien aimé sincèrement que d'ailleurs les
tournois là bas ils ont réunion refaire
des champs maniement de de ce côté là
parce que là ils ont fait dans des dents
des boues pib mais ses pattes c'était
pas aussi exotique par rapport le brésil
dans sa ils ont aussi fait l'afrique du
sud ouais président afrique du sud
savent aussi qu'il faut qu'on peut pas
se plaindre
c'est vrai ça va
les dames ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai surtout bon elle a l'air de me
donne bien aimé manger ligue 1 surtout
là c'était au coût de 8 quand même qu'il
est sorti la dame 1 sortie en b4 et ça
sert pas à grand chose mais lartet
qu'elle a une bonne position en fait vu
que l'option dessin peut être faible
peut-être même par celles ci
mais d'ailleurs hier tournant à prague
en ce moment je crois tu es tu viens
prenant du coup tu pourras les bords tu
pourras aller voir le trop long il se
joue en ce moment plus prisées pendant
ce moment ci donc tu pourras aller voir
ces quatre c4 sacré dimas mais je pense
que oui j'allais dire des trucs toujours
fous 10,6 soit 5 ce salaire de bien tu
n'y as pas besoin de jouer des trucs de
fou pour bien tenir sa écrits noir sur
tout le matériel est égal
as tu parlé d'un gros tournoi du genre
en tournoi à karlsson et tout ça c'est
ça oui ça ça je pense qu'ils auront ce
pass est bientôt en tout cas aux eaux
lagaf au lac à hausser moi pas celle à
une belle peau lisse et en plus elle a
donné sa dame des six adresses adam le
craquage très dommage c'est vraiment
très dommage on sort en ce 3 si c'est
vraiment trop alors je peux je peux
j'essaie de voir si je vais essayer de
voir là-bas trouvé sa partie et on peut
regarder ça
donc c'était ça en fait on peut rien
relevé de son côté donc ici après tours
b 6 l à fait d'armes c2 et les noirs ont
joué le magnifique coup de dingue des
cinq qui ont perdu madame très dommage
surtout que ça mais non mais c'est nimp
en fait ce qu'elle a fait surtout que le
fou il est acquis et superviseur optique
et voulait faire d'un de ses cinq échecs
mois elle voulait faire dans ces cinq
échecs et après à bouger le fou
peut-être à ces super dommage c'est un
terme à osciller pas assez c'est moche
ça moche bon bon bah ça arrive ça arrive
et le temps vient de s'écouler
d'ailleurs donc ça sera leur duo ça
serait leur du bus lot
après cette partie ça sera un bullet
c'est quoi le meilleur à l'eau de
dessiner en vote est-ce qu'elle était
super forme seront donnés ou quoi ouais
c'est vrai que moi ils sont quand même
assez fort mais c'est un mec c'est pas
des essais pas des dix meilleurs
mondiaux en face à sûr mais ils sont
quand même assez fort bah merci hazuki
dis donc c'est sympa mais c'est vrai que
niveau parti a pas trop le suspense en
sachet de la corde
c'est ça manque un peu de suspense des
matches et un précédent alors que là les
matches précédents il y avait en suspens
de fou sur tout le match
le match de l'agglo c'est incroyable ce
qu'elle a gagné elle a gagné 11 et demi
contre 10 ennemis je crois truc du genre
est aussi le match le match d'hier aussi
je crois le match d'hier ils ont joué
les départage pendant 30 minutes de plus
alors que fait à chaque fois il faisait
nul ou alors est gagnée après l'autre
gagné sept sages du rire en temps a fini
on savait jamais qui allait gagner mais
bon tu là on savait depuis le début
c'est ce match c'est ce qui allait se
passer
ouais mais tu peux aller faire un tour
ailleurs on sort on se retient pas ici
si tu veux partir qui veut partir
ouais mais je crois que des signaux
correa s'est qualifié en gagnant en d3
donc belle et cu et là je vous ai fait
un fait c'est juste qualifié quoi donc
elle a clairement mérité sa place mais
aussi un trophée s'est qualifié en
bullet ou à une can en super rapide dès
qu'elle est forte ambulance ou alors là
j'ai eu de la chance vous verrez tombé
sur un tournant et il n'y avait pas des
très fortes soit du coup il y avait huit
tournois qualificatifs avant que ça ne
compense donc il y avait huit joueuses
qui ont été invités par les
organisateurs et huit joueuses
sélectionnées
donc non le j8 joueuse qualifiée voulait
dire qualifié par les tournées en fait
il y avait huit points donc grâce à ça
il ya eu du jeu estime plus qualifiant
en participant aux tournois dont qui
avait détourné de bliss des pas des
tournois de trouille de 5 us noeux je
crois du 3 + 2 il ya pose-t-il son
athlète
donc je sais pas lequel est l'âme et la
réussit alors à faire mais même en du
coup là quand même elle a quand même
réussi donc c'est à dire qu'il mérite sa
place
à 2459 à l'om moi j'ai pas ce qu'il est
arrivé
c'est bizarre si à soi et faire autre
chose optait lequel est telle qu'elle
est et elle fait des études ou alors
effet juste autre chose via ce qu'on
faisait pas un jeu d'échecs professional
parce que sinon c'est vraiment le choix
si elle essayait pro et qu'elle a perdus
et compenser et c'est pas top
alors ya un sacré avantage pour ces
panneaux valeur et peut faire des trous
béants peut-être essayer tout aussi les
pions faire cailler des 5 pouces est
comme ça aussi ramener son endroit ça
devrait bien cabillaud 4 ou 6 peut-être
fou retaper le pion f2 c'est possible
après c'est de faire ça prenait 3 h2k
validé deux peut-être essayer de faire
mes songes
à cet effet
c'est
oh
bon alors la question c'est comment
pousser ses pions peut-être qu'on va
faire des trucs genre e5 peut-être faire
des trucs genre saint caprais faire
cavalier 3 et essayer d'attaquer le pion
le pied en jeu 2 et en plus ce corridor
une fois lié à ces mots l'otan 14
secondes ça va être chaud donc là est
simple ça me plaît bien je vais
cavaillon 3 ou alors je serai en nocture
méprendre le pim s'adonne lappion
bessengue m
ah oui mais il y avait 5 à 8,5 ça fait
beaucoup sa hausse avec le wild 5 et il
doit y avoir des têtes des tours tours
g6 peut-être sur fos est peut-être faire
tout ceci c'est à ce moment là et aussi
le fou bouche de racailles des six qui
le full band 8 chacun des six ou alors
si le four revient en effet tu auras
tout re ol n a pas joué à j'aurais bien
aimé voir tour gc ce calme demain elle
n'a pas joué ouais donc ça c'est gagnant
aussi tour g3a non mais c'est pas si
c'est passé simple promettre fait
l'arrêt attaqué m chez de cette voie non
c'est fini c'est fini ça c'est terrible
prend 1,4 qui arrive
ouais donc t'as pas une très grosse
surprise et le temps et finit d'ailleurs
donc là il ya la pause et après ça sera
l'heure des bullet ça sera déjà l'heure
des bulles est donc ouais donc là il y
aura une petite pause et sa reprendre
rendra bientôt donc à bon moi aussi je
vais faire ma petite pause alors que j'y
retourne et je reviendrai dans un mini
donc à tout de suite les gens
alors elles ont repris non je suis de
retour donc j'espère je n'ai pas loupé
depuis que le jeune femme j'ai pas loupé
deux parties s'y inscrivent raison déjà
fait une autre partie
ok heures que se passe-t-il donc là il
ya un pion faible ans et quatre autres
qu'il faut faire b38 le fond mais en
baby 2 mais elle n'a pas choisi star ça
elle a préféré mais son foulard
peut-être qu'elle veut sortir la tour
anciens pour défendre le bleu qui ont
comme ça ouais je pense qu'elle va
essayer de faire tourner sien et on sait
pas si simple à jouer pour les bains je
pense que l'avantagé plutôt du côté des
noirs ici
pour cette fois c'est bien vu pour
passer là tout ranger 3 c'est pas mal ça
pas mal donc sur tours suite il y aura
peut-être b3 en attendant et après tout
la turquie passant j'ai 3
ouais au hockey donc a fait un tour g3
hockey le faux il est un peu mais on
peut enfermer way très adroit c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment moche je pensais
qu'en bullet hell et s'en sortir et
peut-être mais là elle est déjà pas bien
on n'est déjà pas très bien non c'est
vrai hockey lnah pas faire non sans eau
elle pourrait peut-être prendre la plume
ok là c'est bien pour elle attend tous
pensé 4 il y avait qu à vis à vis ok
donc là et attaque la tour c'est simple
c'est bien
ga peut-être dommage ça demande à ma
chatte ya la prise jeudi et lundi
auquel vous plus vite c'est vrai mais là
il rêve ou bien je crois je vois ces
huit femmes il a du temps devant mais ça
ça va quand même temps qu'elle se bouge
un peu
ok dans sa lettre non je ne veux pas
annuler elle peut remonter mais là ça
risque d'être nulle si elle continue à
répéter le goût de 5,7 pouces et h5 à
elle veut passer la tour e m6 c'est
malin ou ses jolies donc valait mieux
faire retour f cell date butoir 6
d'abord pour défendre le pion et après
peut-être faire dans huit je pense que
ce réceptacle être même gagner mais bon
là du coup est ce que c'est de finir les
gagnantes
je pense pas mais je n'en sais rien en
fait ouais ça donnait gagnant ça ouais
war 3 et 4 et 5 3 f 4 pouces et le pion
f3 pour faire le jeu besoin et après il
faut faire bouger le roi et sa de orbe
est la bonne
adam faut qu'elle fasse elle stable à
9,5 m 5 pi et après f3 fous moi moi j'ai
5 qui a fait ça ça devrait gagner passé
à la paperie l'on commence alors la
pression
elle avait juste à prendre une option en
plus il restait 9 secondes juste trois
options soit il s'est défini mais yuko
l'adc beau mais là c'est beaucoup de
chance au noir non mais là ça va
non ça va de poids du coup elle va
réussir à gagner je pense
faut juste qu'elles prennent de plus en
france enfin qu'elle prenne le pion en
tant que son bail de soi ses proches
mais du coup je pense que larry smith
serait pas ses proches ben ali serait
pas à ses proches
non c'est bien que les gagne autant donc
13 à 4 elle se rend compte
donc là il reste 17 12h07 sept minutes
du match
donc là la diagonale elle devrait être
en avance en la faveur des noirs des
blancs pardon à metz du coup voté la
famille attend à ce que c'était ce qui
était obligé de faire ça non c'est un
honneur de la fermer je pense ouais la
ferme et c'est pas ça parce qu'il valait
mieux garder l'option de faire des trucs
genre des genres des 4 ou alors même c4
noël ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr mais mes
enfants n'y crois pas trop aimé mon el
had et je pense que pour gagner toutes
les parties là toutes les parties
d'affilée
surtout en 17 minutes ça va être
compliqué mais c'est compliqué ça serait
un miracle c'est même pas un miracle en
fait ça sera juste plus que ça ça serait
absolument phénoménale donc c'est ça qui
s'est passé
ouais donc cette finale c'est une heure
ça devrait être assez égal mais bon
c'est ça le temps prévu pour les noirs
parce que à cause des clients faible
donc la dame prend des gars c'était pas
possible à cause d'un v8
yanhel faux
ouais ça devrait largement fin
or sans annulation à ok faudrait que je
mette les les flèches temps je salue m
non aux effets chez moi comment les
mettre
bon ok donc ça ça devrait quand même
mieux parce que ce pion bas et mr dame
aussi
lexus
ok donc c'est l'exemple qu'ils ont fait
nul elles sont fait nul donc bon c'est
un résultat on pas si mal pour popori
bon elle a gagné enfin l onglet mélo
maintenant il faut regarder les mêmes
lots à s'était bien remise chez moi
comme on l'a fait d'ailleurs annoncés
sont des mobiles est ok ok ok ok sonné
le bullet jeu c'est pour ça ça pour ça
que ça a changé
non c'était à totalement égal c'était 7
annuler parce que le client et blanc
allaient à damer le pion noir aussi à
lallaing
donc là il ya des plans doublé mais
peut-être que les blancs peuvent
l'utiliser avec tours deux ans peut-être
et au suivi de cabaye décide par exemple
ce genre de choses
caïds et 6 le sacrifice est ça se tente
même peut-être à après dame g4 aussi aux
amphets kyle et si tu as raismes importe
sa fuite parce que vous prend à peu
prendre ou reprendre rejouer cinq à la
temps là il peut encore le faire car ici
ce qu'elle dit si ça peut faire parce
que là la fille c'est pas possible à
cause de fouet 5 à la fin de son
effroyable 5
pour beaucoup elle peut prendre avec le
a et b avec le pion c'est mieux pour
vous si m6 web bulgarie ouais ouais
en effet
aussi sa perle cavaliers d'ailleurs le
cavaly en d6 séville 2 1 x 3 way elle
l'appelle c'est bien donc surtout prend
des ans il y aura tout reprend d'un
bouge
ok donc aux impasses et gagne ensemble
ce que c'est cool parce qu'il ya dame
s'est cassé pour sa table à non mesdames
c4 qui a eu lieu six oui ça va juste à
bouger l'europe et après il prend en
main ce alors l a pas fait super dommage
non c'est le refus elle aurait pu
simplement gagner après d'un de ses
gardes bref très dommage
bon elle a fait beaucoup de gars font
donc là nulle c'était assez prévisible
ça à la fin c'est de totalement nuls
ouais mais bon elle a vraiment bouger
quelque chose de qui aurait été très
fort
si elle arrive à finir à la haye que la
brouille qui dépend de son adversaire ça
va être pas mal sa lettre sur l'objectif
peut-être faire d'un des 2 6 2
d'attaquer le pion à 6o et ouais si voix
auxquelles a pris donc là là j'aimerais
bien faire bon alors ok des cinq sens
ça gâche un peu notre plan mais eux 5 du
coup ça donne à 4,5 mais c'est pas grave
parce que si le cabinet en là on
l'attaquera sinon si possible soir était
peut-être étais-je et 5 suivi de caelis
mais bon là du coup ses deux enfants
pourront pousser gcard cette eau pour
rendre ça oui ça veut dire merde à sa
famille exact exact
gora rouages cette eau tu parlais de
sueur fois-çi theory ouvrage tattoo où
tu parles de co2 quoi qu'ils pensent des
cas là on peut peut-être aussi les plus
sympas d'avant voujeaucourt bien sûr et
après on essaie de pousser le clan
peut-être qu'on peut faire ouais dame
j'aurais dit d'un mec deux peut être
d'aveux 3 je vois pas trop ce qu'elle
aime pas l le cercle des singles comme
c'est cool ça m'aide elle aurait pu le
faire mais là pas appel
tu es prend des saints qui gagnait le
cavalier par exient gagner rend pure
grâce à grâce au fait qu'il y ait la
taxe qui sent le gars m'a dit wen ont
ils pensé du bullet ça c'est normal
qu'ils aient tellement gaffe à bulles
est donc là et si c'était possible suivi
de foufou et 4 et tout tour f3 qui passe
en a je crois mais bien sûr c'était un
honneur de jus du coup ils prennent
juste au delà et petit [ __ ]
possibles auxquelles a pris elle a pris
en commun continue et une en tant qu on
ans puis on faible en d4
mais il est noir ont pu en fait blanc
des 5 donc on peut faire damer f3 pour
essayer d'attaquer les pions ouh là là
il y aura g5 celui de h4 peut-être
qu'ils gagnent l'info j'ai l'impression
saga nafoussa
tout légèrement féminin ah oui on
pourrait leur créer leurs propres titres
donc là c'est encore gagnant ou la tuer
h3 ok donc l échange l échange mais donc
c'est pas clair alors ce que le pian hdi
peut causer des problèmes
si les bleus arrivent à pousser les
pions ça devrait aller mais ce plan de
oui ça devrait aller quand même
ça devrait l'être parce que ses pions
sont pas sont pas capables ouais ouais
ça avance ça oui oui j'ai compris j'ai
compris c'est s est s était passé
c'était assez assez drôle d'air donc là
il reste plus que sept minutes
ouais tu peux ici et même où 15 compte 5
ça fait ça fait ça fait mal quand même
c'est la famille exact
donc la voix peut-être moi j'allais dire
c'est fou c'est sympa ça marchera jamais
parce que c'est trop défendu la troupe
possible et le kavé lui-même faut lire
paul et henri saint egrève c'est ce
qu'il a fait
bon ça arrache ça marche
ouh là là c'est gros avantage déjà pour
les nombres je pense que grâce à
peut-être y aura kg jesse s'est aussi
attaqué le q4 venir en d3 aussi ça a
l'air pas mal
ouais venir en d3 surtout pour attaquer
puis aurait 4 pour prendre pour mieux
attaquer
bah ok bah merci pour tes forte blague
c'est un mis l'ambiance c'était une
bonne journée à toi aussi
et du coup nous on a presque fini aussi
parce qu'il va s'occuper cinq minutes et
après ça ça sera pas en habit y aura pas
d partagent un parce qu'entre 15 15 e et
5 ya pas trop de ce passé pas très
proche donc voilà donc ça sera sûrement
les parties décisives hier mon avis on
aura plus que peu plus que trois ou
quatre avant la fin août m30d 3 ouais
ouais donc bon là les noirs ont quand
même une qualité plus donc ça c'est
savais pas pense à lui ça ne c'est
beaucoup mais nous c'est beaucoup mais
ils n'auront eu mis une seconde a
attendu face à quatre secondes au delà
perdu autant aux essarts vendée est la
6e contre caen 15
ça serait cool qu'elle avait calé
continue avec 20 qu'elle finisse avec
sept ou huit 8 ça serait d'oeuvre
tiens donc et entre la tâche
non mais je crois qu'ils n'arrêtent
jamais en fait ils arrêtent ils arrêtent
bah disons même si même si stéphane au
bal avec elle avait eu 27 0 par exemple
il aurais tu as même pas arrêté il
aurait quand même pas arrêter parce que
ça s'arrête juste quand le timing
finlande par le times descendre à 0 donc
d'abord qu'on a 10 étaient des cinq plus
de après sa passe à 3 puces de mais à la
fin c'est cette ville est donc une fois
que tout ça va terminer c'est là que ça
s'arrête pas il n'y a pas de way ainsi
si quelqu un en avantage incroyable
comme ça veut rien dire ça veut pas dire
que c'est la fin pardon c'est bien sûr
qu'il va gagner mais les arrête pas le
match c'est sale c'est donc là ça a
l'air d'être une finale de france hasard
c'est typique avec le pion h qui va être
faibles faisait qu'on peut faire des 6
et 7 pouces et juste a lancé oui donc
c'est ce qu'elle a fait
comme c'est la règle ça va pas mal plus
prisées en prêt en pousse des quatre
c'est super cool ça
voilà donc la paix que faut faire
cavaillé f1 pour passer en dix enfants
pour aller en g3 pour essayer de
défendre contre l'échec mais bon elle a
choisi de faire autre chose et avec f3
c'est vrai qu'elle défend bien mais
c'est pas massivement pour ses sets ça
fait pas grand chose la casse et si
c'est contre les branles faut donc
l'attaqué que prendre 24 mai il y aura
tous rage pas sur quelle vie et royal a
prises dans le cadre suivi de fou au
csis a peut-être que nice était aussi
possible de faire tourner autour des
trois heures
moi mais c'est ok donc là c'est pas si
clair qu'à payer 3 peut-être ça peut
être dangereux
ouais ça alors je pense que l'avantagé
était passé du côté des blancs sur
toujours là on emmène un temps
magnifique on essaie de pousser les
flots
ouais tour je sais c'est donc sur wabush
dès qu'on peut même pas requérir 6 donc
la huawei f5 salaires vraiment top ou
même v6 en fait pour passer le roi aux
25 suivi de roi des six ainsi ça a l'air
vraiment mortel ça a l'air vraiment top
ça vraiment sachets gagnant bien sûr
c'est archi gagnant du coude et des blu
mai mais à un moment donné
d ici avec les normes avait quand même
des sacrée chance mais elle a hélas elle
hadoop est ok donc c'était pas c'était
prévisible donc il reste 18 secondes
il reste 18 secondes
donc maintenant 13 secondes mais du coup
vu qu'elles ont et vont repris la partie
donc une fois que le times s'arrêtera
pas ils vont quand même continuer cette
partie et donc pas l'arrêter au milieu
donc oui voilà donc cette partie sera la
dernière
c'est parti sur la dernière et donc
voilà elle arrivera même pas à faire la
moitié des fonds de stéphane aubin c'est
dommage
donc là peut-être poussé ces simples qui
sera fait de mal
quelque 17 u aura f4 je pense propreté
gestion sur la frc un stand quand même
mais non c'est peut-être pas top
je suis surprise en plus ça ou vous la
colagne aura peut-être tours 8
après le client est roi sera aussi
faibles il faut éviter ça france des
preuves à mai mais peut-être que fout gk
c'était beau s'il est en fête
pour attac il a tour à tour obligé de
bouger il y as dame c'est cet etf ou g4
sur f5
en fait la prise en passant du coup j'ai
quatre ça gagne je pense mais elle a
fait du 6 et la simplifier c'est bizarre
j'ai super bizarre chez moi pour la
saison
craquage aucune idée pour la femis
absolument augmenter donc là déjà ses
gros avantage mais elle peut faire tout
d'am dam à 6 peut-être pour attaquer ça
aurait pu aussi wifu dessins que c'est
bien par exemple si si c'est bien pour
tenir
elle défend trop
peut-être d'amd ans pour là pour passer
la dame de ce côté là ça peut se tenter
dom bien ok donc elle veut contenir
défendre ses pions ok elle va remettre
ça d'amendé en tête raquette non
théâtre et c'est de passer la poule à
ok donc les en fines u15 ont fait nul
donc au hockey non mais je pense pas que
ça reprend lorsque le temps est fini
donc je pense que c'est juste un bug
wayne on se reprend pas ça reprend pas
donc bah c'est la fin donc stéphane
barret gagner ses ennemis contre 6,7 me
donc c'est quand même un sacré 5,8 égard
entre les deux donc j'ai juste voulu
montrer sa selle et ça c'est le bracket
donc voilà ce qui se passe aussi à ça
c'est les joueurs qui ont gagné
précédemment l'agglo à gagny bibi ça va
gagner et aussi le match d'hier qui n'a
pas été commenté c'était entre entre
coussine uk dans nos valises mais ça ça
va pas ça pas été compté un corps au met
mais bon et donc voilà donc ça c'est ce
qui se passe et voilà ça c'est des
appareils mans 2-2 demain entre irina
croche et mana banide
donc ça sera ça le match le match de
demain donc je crois que c'est un peu
plus tôt que d'habitude je vais juste
vérifier mon calendrier je crois que oui
donc en fait c'est un peu plus tard ces
trente minutes plus tard qu'aujourd'hui
donc voilà donc bah merci d'abord
d'avoir regarder d'abord j'espère que
vous avez apprécié les commentaires du
coup je vous dis à demain alors parce
que je serai de retour pour les
commentaires de main du coup va passer
une bonne soirée et monde et